Happiness isn't something, we're not a victim of it.
It doesn't just happen to us.
It's it's happening all the time.
(upbeat music)
The single most positive and effective tool
is the five second rule.
Whatever situation happened,
didn't happen to you, it happened for you.
And I could see that those who were over-managed
were lacking an agency.
Sleep is the single most effective thing
that we can do each day
to reset the health of our brain and our body.
Happy holidays, everybody.
Welcome.
I must say it has been fun
revisiting these conversations
and splicing together this special episode.
2021 was a transformative year in so many ways.
And part two of this recap tradition does not disappoint.
Today, as I look back on the year,
I'm just filled with so much gratitude,
not just for all of the incredible individuals
who have shared their time and their wisdom
and their hearts with me,
but really for all of you guys, for the listeners,
I don't take your attention and support for granted.
I relish in our community.
And this recap practice
is just one way that I can honor all of you,
a way of saying thank you
in this spirit of positive change,
because I believe in the power we all have
to do and be better and to own an actualize our best,
most authentic selves.
And so with that being said,
what better way to kick things off today
than by sharing the wisdom of author
and one of my personal heroes, Steven Pressfield.
Revered for his creative prolificacy,
Stephen has 20 books to his name,
including a book that radically changed my life.
A book that I gift more than any other book,
"The War of Art."
Steven joined me on episode 584,
serving up truth, big and small,
on honing creativity,
overcoming resistance,
the importance of persistence
and why art is about discipline, not talent.
Kindly hit that subscribe button,
and please enjoy this excerpt
from my conversation with Steven Pressfield.
I call it resistance with a capital R
and like if we had a typewriter
or a keyboard in front of me now,
or you've got one there,
with a blank screen or a blank page in it,
you would feel, we would feel,
a force radiating off that page, a negative force,
trying to push you away from it, right.
And it would take, that's what I call resistance.
It would be the same thing as if
we went out and bought an exercise bike or a treadmill,
and we brought it home to the house, oh, we're going to,
and suddenly we realize we're coming up
with every excuse in the world not to get on that treadmill.
So resistance is this negative force of self-sabotage
that will work against us
anytime we try to move from a lower level to a higher level,
ethically, morally, creatively.
If you have an idea for a book,
if you have an idea for a podcast,
if you have an idea for this studio
or something that you want to do,
and I want to ask you about this Rich,
a voice will come into your head immediately that will say,
who are you to do, put this thing together.
This has been done a million times
and it's been done better than you ever could do
or ever would do.
You're too old.
You're too young.
You're too fat.
You're too skinny.
You don't have enough education.
You have too much education, et cetera, et cetera.
And that negative force is universal.
I can tell you from the thousands of emails I've got,
and not only is it universal,
but it's the same voice in every, in all of our heads.
You know, it may be tailored a little bit to you or to me,
but it's, it's the same voice.
And I was never aware of that.
When I first started to write as a 24 year old,
resistance just kicked my ass all over the place.
And I, I, you know,
I went through a lot of stuff
before I finally kind of said to myself,
you know what, there's a force out there
that's working against me.
You know, it's not just,
it's not just something I'm inventing.
There is a real force out there just like gravity,
just like, you know, the transit of Venus across the sky.
And once I could sort of give a name to it, then,
then I could say, okay,
now I have something I can deal with.
How can I overcome this?
Can I develop habits that will help me overcome it?
Can I organize my day in such a way?
Can I change my mindset in such a way?
And so, anyway, that's kind of my definition of resistance.
Right.
Well, the first step seems to be
disassociating your identity from the resistance itself,
because I think what we all kind of do is,
is self identify with that.
That is part of the--
That's a great way
of putting it, Richard.
I've never heard that before.
That's exactly it.
Well, you have talked about, you know,
this idea that exists outside of yourself, right.
If you're just thinking, well, I can't do it.
This is me telling myself this,
as opposed to this external force
that we can, you know,
define as this pernicious entity working at odds with our,
this, our effort to climb to that, you know, elevated place.
But what was it that was like the light switch for you
that allowed you to kind of come to that realization?
Was it just pain?
You know, it was pain, I guess, but, you know,
I can't actually remember.
There was like a moment.
Right.
When I said that, or if there was to myself, oh,
this is resistance.
It just, you know, just over time, I guess.
I mean, there was a moment
that sort of where things turned around in that way for me,
but I don't think I,
I identified a force as resistance.
But what you just said, Richard, is exactly right,
the, of disassociating this concept of resistance,
this fact of resistance from your own identity.
Like when we hear this voice in our head
that says you're not good enough,
it's all been done, et cetera, et cetera.
What makes that so powerful against us
is we think it's our own thoughts.
We think, oh, that's me assessing the situation objectively,
but it's not.
It's this other siren voice, this,
this force that's just out there.
That's a fact of nature.
And once we can say, oh, that's not me.
That kind of is the key to the whole thing.
Next up is a really powerful clip
that's excerpted from perhaps
the most emotionally resonant episode of the year
coming from elite marathoner and ultra marathoner
Tommy Rivers Puzey
offering poignant words of wisdom
gleaned from his recent near-fatal battle
with a rare and aggressive form of lymphoma.
You know, I remember being very aware that it was serious.
And any, anytime you have something
that's going on with your respiratory system, you,
you really quickly lose your ego.
I mean, you, there's not much bartering.
Then you can't,
you can't really tough your way through that.
You know, you take away somebody's oxygen and it's just
a matter of minutes and you're,
you're begging for somebody, something,
anything to save you.
I mean, that's why,
it's like being waterboarded, you know.
And, and there's a reason why, gosh,
that's so effective because there's this,
there's this fear that comes over you when
everything protective within your body is telling you
you're going to die.
Like you're, you've got seconds, you know,
unless you change something and,
you know, you become desperate and,
and whatever it is, you know,
whatever it is that that needs to be done to,
to be able to make you stop feeling that you're willing to,
you're willing to do it.
You're willing to concede.
And
yeah.
And yeah, that was kind of,
it's kind of where things started to just go blurry for me,
'cause
after that, it was,
that was in July.
I think it was probably
November before I.
Like your next memory.
Yeah, before I finally--
Where you in and out of consciousness?
Yeah.
You were,
you just don't have recollection of that.
I do.
That's where things get really,
really
difficult to decipher.
What it feels like is, I mean, I've been told now that it,
that it's amnesia, retrograde amnesia and, you know,
not having enough oxygen for so many weeks and months
that there's, you know,
irreparable brain damage and things like that.
And
what it felt like was that all of these files that I had
over the last year,
like if I can have a year and then,
you know, I'll gladly go.
And I've made it, it's been a year.
Yeah.
Gosh, and then you get selfish.
You're like, okay, five more,
20 more, 50 more.
Right.
You know.
Cause we're humans, man.
Right.
Exactly.
But I mean, it, it doesn't,
it doesn't get any better than this.
It's, it really doesn't.
And I mean, the tragedy is that we,
that we don't see it until afterwards, you know.
I mean, I've been thinking about
people say like, and they lived
and they lived happily ever after like the,
the operative verb there is lived, you know.
They were,
they were alive and that's why,
that's why they were able to,
that's why it was happily ever after.
Then they died and it becomes a fucking tragedy, you know.
Right.
But like, gosh,
life is incredible.
I mean, it, it just,
as bad as it seems, as hard as it seems,
it's just such a,
a gift to be able to do it.
And we talk about
how tragic it is when somebody,
when something happens, you know, somebody dies,
somebody gets sick,
there's an accident, there's a disaster.
And as though,
as though that's,
that's out of the norm and,
and in reality,
the fact that we're alive, it's just,
it's just a miracle.
I mean, the fact that we're,
that we're here, that we're,
becomes hard to talk about this stuff
because you can't express it in ways
that haven't been expressed in just such cliche terms,
you know, but the fact that we're
living and breathing and talking and all of this,
with everything that's going on.
On a space rock.
Yeah, exactly.
That emits oxygen that we can breathe.
And we give it back CO2
as we're hurdling through space.
I mean, it's all insane, right.
Spinning 16,000 miles an hour.
Our brains can't,
can't really, you know,
grok that whole thing.
I mean, of course, obviously we intellectually understand
like that life is a miracle.
Sure.
But we can't fully embody that
or appreciate that on a moment to moment basis.
And, you know, in my experience,
people who have experienced certain types of trauma
or life altering, you know, situations like yourself,
come out of those experiences
with obviously this renewed appreciation,
but there's kind of a timeline,
like that dissipates over time.
Like it's hard to hold onto that, right.
And so here you are a year later, like,
I feel like you're, you really are holding onto that.
You know, you really are in the moment,
like when we first sat down and you're like,
great, man, I'm so happy.
Like I could feel it, like that's real.
And I think that's an incredible gift for all of us to like,
hear you express that, for you to fully embody that.
And a powerful reminder
of just how precious all of this is
and how fleeting and how delicate and fragile.
Yeah.
And I just want to,
like, I want a piece of that.
Like I wanna, like, I wanna,
I wanna feel that on a soul level
in the way that you feel it.
But the lucky part is that as good as things are, there,
they'll get bad again for all of us, you know.
I guess the key is to not waste that suffering.
When it comes, like, see it as,
see it as a gift, see it as an,
as an opportunity to open our eyes and,
and to be able to really,
to value, you know, what it is that we have
is normal a normal day, you know,
just realizing how incredible that is.
And the tragedy is that we don't recognize it
until after the fact.
But everything is it's so cyclical, you know,
everything that is good,
anytime we're in,
we're having a good time, a comfortable time.
Life is good, you know.
We can be 100% guaranteed that it's going to get bad again,
you know, and as bad as it is,
it can be 100% guaranteed that it's going to get good again,
you know, and,
it's just being able to see all of it all at once and,
and recognize, recognize what is good and,
and be able to really value it as it's happening.
Because, you know, like I was saying, there is,
there is no idealistic future, you know,
where it's just gonna,
it's gonna all be right.
And we're just going to be happy, you know.
Happiness, isn't something, we're not a victim of it.
It doesn't just happen to us, you know.
It's happening all the time
and it's our ability to see it and recognize it.
And
yeah, it's just,
it's just incredible, really.
Next up is author,
education luminary and fellow Stanford classmate,
Julie Lythcott-Haims
on the pod, promote her new book,
"Your Turn: How To Be an Adult".
We discussed everything
from the importance of honing conversation skills
to fostering curiosity
and how it can all grow up just a little bit more.
Childhood had changed.
So parents were arriving differently on campus.
They were arriving and staying,
they weren't just dropping you off or helping you move in.
They felt they had a role to play
in the day-to-day management of life
in the life of their child.
And I found myself thinking, you know,
this child could be in the Marines,
but here they are not putting their lives in danger.
They're at a well-resourced university,
which you're paying a tremendous amount
for them to attend, quite likely.
What are you so afraid of parent?
Why is it that you think you need to be the one
to have the run of the mill conversation
with a faculty member,
to get involved if there's a roommate dispute,
to attend an overseas studies orientation,
because you don't think your child can go abroad
unless you've had the orientation
so that we know how we can be successful abroad?
We listened to the meta, to the,
we listened to the pronouns changing.
It was we're going abroad.
We've gotten into this seminar.
So those were some of the changes I noticed,
and my job was to root for young people to thrive.
And I could see that those who were over-managed
were lacking in agency,
and I found myself asking,
hey kid, have you ever made a choice?
Have they let you make a choice?
Or are you just incredibly good at doing what you're told?
Yeah.
And it saddened me.
Yeah, it produces a certain handicap
where the child, not only lacks self-efficacy,
but that produces lower self esteem
and a lower sense of their own inherent capabilities.
And certainly, you know, Stanford is your experience,
but this is not, you know, endemic simply to Stanford.
Not at all.
This is a,
this is a nationwide, if not a global thing.
Absolutely.
That is so fascinating.
And I feel like has only continued to metastasize.
So that catch all kind of umbrella phrase for this is,
is helicopter parenting, of course,
or, you know, the tiger mom phenomenon.
What is your sense of,
of how this started and how we got to this situation?
Very interestingly,
there are a set of changes happening in this country,
in the mid 80s that conspired to
in the aggregate change all of childhood.
So in no particular order, Rich five things,
stranger danger was born with a made for TV movie, "Adam",
about the abduction and murder of Adam Walsh in 1983.
And everybody watched it, there was no internet.
All of your entertainment came through the big screen
or the small screen or your headphones.
Everybody tuned in for that show,
and it scared the bejesus out of everybody.
So stranger danger was 83.
And that, and then that guy's dad
became the host of, what was the show that he did.
"America's Most Wanted".
Yeah.
John Walsh, exactly.
And missing kids began appearing on,
photos began appearing on milk cartons.
And yes, occasionally children were abducted by strangers.
And it is, of course, as we know, as parents,
the most horrific thing we can imagine,
and yet children are more likely to die
at the hands of a family member
than they are at the hands of a stranger.
They're more likely to die as a passenger in a car,
Yet we drive them in cars constantly
to get them to and from their activities.
So we should reshaped childhood around
the very, very, very infinitesimal likelihood
of the stranger harming our children.
And we can really trace that back to that movie "Adam" 1983.
The play date was born in 1984.
Kids used to play with each other.
We found each other, right, Rich.
It was like, where are the bikes?
That's where my friends are.
That was a Gen X childhood.
That changed.
Parents started arranging play with other parents,
deciding with whom and when,
but also watching over it, hovering, micromanaging.
Are they playing with the right things?
Are they bored?
Let me help them.
The self-esteem movement,
give them ribbons and trophies,
certificates and awards just for playing soccer
or just for swimming rather than for being any good at it.
The notion that we need to always praise.
Great job, Billy,
you slid down a slide.
Great job, you didn't hit Jack, you know.
"A Nation At Risk" was published, saying
American teenagers needed to be, you know,
more high achieving vis-a-vis
their international counterparts.
We needed more testing,
more teaching to the test.
All of these things meant
that childhood was now watched and managed by parents.
We also got safer in cars
with seatbelt laws and car seat laws
and bike helmet laws, and bicycles.
We got safer in our transportation.
It led to this mindset of,
you can put a helmet on them always,
you can bubble wrap every aspect of their environment.
Prepare the road for the kid
instead of prepare the kid for the road.
All of those things happened
in the span of three to five years.
The first kids to come to college en mass
with parents who couldn't let go in the late 90s
where the first have been subjected to play dates in 1984.
Yeah.
And it, and why does it persist?
Because it works, Rich.
When you stand next to the rock wall
and prevent your kid from falling onto the plastic woodchips
they go unharmed.
So you've saved them in that moment,
but over the longterm,
your kid hasn't developed that kinesthetic sense
of how their body works
or how to do something different or better next time.
So short-term win, long-term loss.
Right, and on top of that,
it's all set up within the construct of performance.
Right.
How do I set my kid up to get into the best college?
Like that is the ultimate end game.
Right.
And so when you're looking at short-term,
short-term gains,
it's all oriented around academic performance,
making sure that they have the appropriate extracurriculars
and the only way to ensure that
is this level of over-involvement.
Right.
But of course, even in the successful cases
where a kid ends up at Stanford,
that kid ends up knocking on your door, you know,
having, having all kinds of, you know,
mental issues or self-esteem issues or, you know,
body dysmorphia.
I'm sure it shows up in a million different ways
where they're handicapped and unable
to really figure out how to live
and exist and thrive on their own.
That's exactly right.
So we've done the thinking for them,
the planning for them,
the troubleshooting,
the fixing,
the managing, the handling all in furtherance
of these outcomes we think lead to a successful life.
And it's almost like we take our helicopter rotors
and we lift them in the helicopter
and arrive them at the future we have in mind.
And then we can say, look, you've arrived.
You're here.
And then the kid is bewildered at the place of arrival
because they haven't done the heavy lifting.
They've certainly worked hard.
It's not to say that kids aren't hardworking in this,
in this context.
But they've been so over-managed and over helped,
they really are unfamiliar with their own selves.
And in my first book, "How To Raise an Adult",
I call it existential impotence,
unfamiliar with the self.
My sense is that there's a pendulum that swings
and that, that pendulum swings generation to generation
where parents end up parenting
in opposition to wit to the way that they were parented
to ensure that their kid gets what they feel
like they didn't get.
Right.
Sure.
So if you have the gen X-ers,
who were the latchkey kids
who were completely unattended to,
they're going to be the ones who are more likely to show up
and over parent.
Is that how you feel like it works or are,
have we arrived in a situation now
where the pendulum is kind of locked in this place
where parents are fixated in an unhealthy way
on how their kids are doing and performing?
I certainly agree with you that
many of us want to parent
either the opposite of how we were raised,
or we appreciate how we were raised,
and we want to do it the exact same way.
We don't seem to have room for nuance.
I want to point out that it was the baby boomers
that started the helicopter parenting phenomenon.
We gen X-ers inherited it
because you're in a community
and you see how other parents
are doing their kids' homework in the fourth grade
and the seventh grade.
Well, how are you not going to do your kid's homework
because you need your kid to keep up, right.
So we arrived as parents
in an environment where helicopter parenting
was already in many communities, the norm.
And I find it ironic the baby boomers
who questioned authority.
I mean, that was their,
that was their bumper sticker.
When they were young,
they were now questioning authority
on behalf of their own kids.
They had forgotten that they created
and matured their own voice by using it.
And instead, they sort of treated their own kids
like little pets and projects
that they would continually question authority
on their behalf.
Yeah.
With gen X, you know,
many of us can appreciate the freedoms
of that latchkey childhood.
Yes, there were examples that were neglectful and harmful,
and none of us want to replicate that.
But you see in the gen X memes on social media,
the kind of lauding,
the pride of like, you know,
look what I was able to do.
Look what my childhood entailed.
There's pride in that.
And I hope that gen X-ers listening will ask themselves,
why am I not offering that same degree of freedom
to my own child?
Why do I want less for them?
Despite what you might think,
Alzheimer's is not a genetic inevitability
and a diagnosis need not come with a death sentence.
So how do we take an insurance policy out against succumbing
to these kinds of neurodegenerative diseases?
Well, neurology duo doctors, Dean and Ayesha Sherzai
joined me on episode 589 to break down the basics
of optimizing brain health.
Here's a snippet from that insightful exchange.
Nobody wants to befall this fate, right?
And, and you know, when we're young and vital,
we think we're bulletproof
and this is never going to happen.
But these diseases start to take root early in our lives.
We don't see the symptoms for many years.
So it's all about these habits that we form
around diet and lifestyle.
So set us up with this,
this paradigm that you guys have come up with,
and we can walk through some of these habits
that you guys have realized
have been extremely helpful in managing symptoms
and preventing people from headed down this path.
Sure.
So not to go into the depth and details of the science,
which we could do,
and we probably will spend some hours just going into it.
But when you look at the basis of the pathology
that takes place in the brain,
and the body for that, for that matter is,
you know, just a few processes.
These are inflammatory processes, oxidation,
abnormalities in metabolism of glucose or energy,
and abnormalities in the metabolism of lipid.
These are the four main pathways
that cause damage to the vasculature,
the blood vessels in the brain,
and it causes damage to the neurons
and the neural connections as well.
And when you look at the mechanism of how these come about,
they're very closely linked to your lifestyle.
So it has to do with food,
with the way you move and exercise,
with stress management,
with sleep, my goodness,
sleep such an important part of our day,
and also how we connect socially,
emotionally to our communities.
And whether it's, you know,
studies coming from, say, for example,
in Columbia University,
where I trained from the Northern Manhattan study
or from the Russia university studies
or from the Adventist health study,
different studies from around the world.
When you look at the factors that stand out,
that contribute to better brain health,
it's nutrition,
it's exercise,
it's stress,
it's sleep.
And the one that we added is cognitive activity.
So.
That's the O, the optimism.
That's right.
So, when we wrote the first book,
we came with this acronym, NEURO,
N-E-U-R-O, of course,
it's a self-explanatory
and it was good because we're neurologists
and helped us a lot too.
It all came together.
It came together and, you know.
N is for nutrition,
E is for exercise,
U is for unwind, which is stress management.
Not just getting rid of stress,
but increasing good stress and getting rid of bad stress.
And R is for restorative sleep,
deep restorative sleep that helps cleanse the brain.
And it has its own function
and optimization of cognitive activity.
Right.
Some of these, if not all of them,
feel like common sense.
And yet also, I mean,
I think the nutrition piece,
everybody knows, you've got to,
if you want to take care of your body, you gotta eat, right.
Right.
Sleep, exercise,
challenging yourself, mentally,
being in a community of people that you're connected to.
These are all things that we,
we kind of intuitively know are good for our health.
The nutrition piece, would you say that's,
is there one that stands out as more important
than the others?
Or do these all just work,
obviously this is a holistic thing,
so they're all interconnected?
But if you had to pick one,
is that even possible?
I don't think it's fair--
I guess if you don't sleep at all
and you eat a perfect diet, it's not gonna matter.
No.
I think it's the multifaceted nature of this
that actually makes a big difference.
And when you look at different communities
and individuals as well, you know, they're,
they might excel in one thing,
but they might be falling behind on others.
And I mean, it's understandable.
We can't really control everything,
but all of them are important.
What would you say?
No, I fully agree with you.
I think all of it has to be done.
And it's incredibly empowering to know that
because every time we say that somebody says,
oh my, you know, my friend did all of it,
but no, none of us did all of it.
And we're talking about living a,
let's, the food part is pretty specific.
I mean, not, we don't have that many communities
that lived in the way that we were talking about.
And we we'll talk about it.
You know, as far as whole food,
whole food, plant-based.
We're talking about exercise, significant exercise.
We're not talking about whenever we talk to our patients
say, oh, I got, Dean, I'm fine.
I would do the gardening.
I do the walk, no.
Or for example, my patients,
when they say I'm walking all day long
from my living room to the kitchen,
back to the living room.
That's not exercise.
It's gotta be significant amount of exercise.
And then stress management.
It's not about just getting rid of bad stress.
By the way we, none of us are doing that well.
And it's not just because you meditate.
Meditation is phenomenal, but it's gotta be an all day,
but also have a good stress, which is a perf.
One of the things that actually gets people
to the dementia stage fastest
is what they did throughout their life
as far as cognitive activity and challenge.
That's profoundly important.
Sleep.
None of us do sleep well.
Just because we took some medicine,
we're talking about restorative sleep,
where people go through the circadian, you know,
the four phases of sleep,
four to five times at night deeply.
We invest in incredible resorts.
We've been invited to different venues.
I say, take that money, and we're not going to tell,
put it in a, in your bedroom.
There's a reason why we're knocked out.
Evolutionarily, how would it make sense
that you are subject to the being mauled by bears and lions
for one third of your life, unless it was that important.
So sleep and investing in sleep is profoundly important.
We study, we're doing the largest one with the sleep study
is shows that 70% increased risk of dementia
for those who have bad sleep.
And then there's optimization,
which is challenging mental activity.
If you think you retired
and you can go lie down on the beach,
that's great for few months.
But if you continue,
that's going to be the fastest point
of decline for cognition.
Because if this brain,
which is consuming 25% of your body's weight
and realizes, oh, I'm not being used,
especially at a time where you're aging.
You know what it will do?
It will actually shrink more rapidly.
So all of it has to be done
and all of them have to be done together.
But the beauty is
if they're done and it's not just a diet dijour,
or New year resolution, run or walk,
and if it's lifestyle,
and especially if it's lived lifestyle,
which is what we were trying to do in communities,
we're talking about 90% reduction
in Alzheimer's, dementia, stroke,
without any biohacking or vitamin dijour
or any of that stuff,
with regular things you have in your, you know,
in your environment.
And I think one of the focus of our study,
which is, you know,
the largest community-based study in the country now
in these cities is the applicability of this knowledge.
I think we have tremendous amount of information
about the kind of diet
and the kind of exercises that are good for the brain,
even stress management, so on and so forth.
But what we haven't really focused on,
what I don't see much of is
bridging that gap between the knowledge that we have,
the incredible amount of information that we have,
and how people apply it at their homes.
That's always the trick.
It really is.
Right.
And so I think
more focus needs to go towards that.
The translation of all this amount of information we have.
When it comes to Phoenix like personal transformation,
there really is no one quite like Karamo Brown who
overcame tremendous adversity to enliven the best in others.
The culture expert on Netflix is massive hit show,
"Queer Eye", Karamo is a father,
is a former social worker,
psychotherapist, author, and just overall stellar human.
Here's a look in his powerful story
that has led him to the life of service he lives today.
When did you know the sexual identity aspect of,
of growing up, you know, come to be a thing?
I mean, you can't,
you sort of came to terms with that around 16 or so?
15.
Yeah.
It came across very quickly.
I mean, you know,
Zach Morris on "Saved By the Bell" helped that a lot.
You know, I kind of figured it out very quickly,
like, oh, I liked boys.
And so I think the journey to accepting love myself
was a difficult one
because my father was Jamaican, is Jamaican,
and the music and the culture previously,
they've gotten a lot better,
subscribe to a lot of homophobic ways.
And so there was a song called "Boom Bye Bye"
by an artist called Buju Banton.
And the song went like this boom bye bye
in a Bati boy, which means homosexuals head.
You're not supposed to promote these nasty men.
You have to kill them dead.
And that song would be playing
at family functions consistently.
And it had a great beat and people are dancing to it.
And the whole song is a
bout killing any gay men onsite that are,
and this was like number one on the radio,
and number 10 on the radio here in the states.
So I want you to imagine a popular song
that's promoting killing gay men
and I'm five, seven, eight, nine,
and these songs are playing.
And so I, it made me feel fearful for my own life.
It made me feel,
you know, unsure about the love that my parents really have,
because if you could sing that song,
unknowing that I was gay,
then do you really love me?
Once I say this to you, are you going to try to kill me?
You know, those are the types of things
that you play in your head.
That's horrible, man.
Yeah.
You know, but I think about that, you know, we still,
haven't gotten to a place with some rap pop, you know,
some rock lyrics.
You know, they still promote this.
And people don't realize that, you know,
you saying no homo
has a connotation to someone who could be,
who identify as part the LGBTQ community
and who was having self-esteem issues.
And every time you say no homo,
how does that affect their self esteem?
Because you're saying that if I do something,
no homo means it's not, it's bad.
So like, I, I'm not bad.
That's bad.
I'm not bad.
And so I think it's just about being clear about
what are you subscribing to
and like really watching your language,
because language has power of how it affects people's mood,
self-esteem, growth, everything.
Yeah.
Wow, that's heavy and you're, are you, where,
where are you at with your dad these days?
We have a,
we have a like, you're good , I'm good.
Like, hey, you know, you stay there.
The problem is, is that even my father is 70 now.
I've, we had many years that we didn't talk at all.
But then like, as I got older,
I did try to reach out and he just could not.
He just still to this day cannot reconcile
his religion with his relationship with his son.
And I think that's a problem.
When you can't reconcile your religion
with your relationships, then there's an issue there.
Because for me, the religion is teaching you
to have healthy relationships through love.
But somehow the Bible is then teaching
a different version of what
could be coming out of other people's mouth
then was supposed to be.
And so he just never been able to reconcile it.
And so I had to come to the place and say, you know what,
since you can't reconcile,
reconcile that decision,
I have to make a decision for myself.
I have to love me more than I love you.
I have to trust me more than I trust you.
I have to be there for myself
more than you could ever be there for me.
And then that was sort of the,
the first step in taking away the pressure
of feeling like I have to have
this relationship with my father,
just because he has a title father.
Right, right, that's the thing.
I mean, I feel like
most people have some version of issues with their parents,
and it's the rare case
that somebody can really process it
and heal from it and get to the other side of it where
they're not carrying around this burdensome, you know,
resentment and anger.
And, you know, constantly looking in the rear view mirror,
like analyzing what that experience was like,
like that takes a lot of work
and most people just compartmentalize it and move on.
Well one of the things that I used to tell myself,
and I try to help,
especially when I worked in social services,
I would tell kids as sort of a,
something that's springboard them
to a happier, healthier life
is that whatever situation happened
didn't happen to you.
It happened for you.
And I think that language right there,
it didn't happen to me.
It happened for me.
It's such a beautiful way of helping you to understand that,
yes, you had an experience that was traumatic,
but what could you learn from this experience?
How can you grow?
How can you be healthier?
How can you be the best version of yourself?
How can you start to heal?
Because when you say it happened to me,
you live in this place of letting the trauma overtake you.
You it's always like, this is, this happened to me.
I wasn't good enough.
I wasn't strong enough to handle this.
What did I do to make this, allow this to happen?
Why wasn't I loved enough?
You start to do all these whys instead of saying,
this happened for me
so that I could understand that I could be stronger,
that I could love myself.
And so when I think about the relationship
that I have with my father and uncles
who couldn't reconcile their religion
with their relationship with me, because of my sexuality,
I say, you know what that happened for me
so that I could be here today, stronger,
loving myself more versus it happened to me.
Yeah.
It's easier to be on the other side of it though,
and look at it that way, like, like intellectually,
yeah, of course.
But when you're in it,
you're when you're mired in it,
it's very hard to like see your way through
and to really grab onto that.
Oh, 100%.
That's why I think that they should teach meditation.
I think one of the things that I think
that they should have not taken out of school
was quiet time.
I think, you know, they got it right
in kindergarten and pre-K when you have quiet time,
because what would happen
is that it would allow all the kids to settle their,
their nerves,
to take a moment to reflect, to recharge.
And I think we get into this as a culture, as a society.
It's like, you have to go, go, go, go, go.
And you don't look at social media, everything,
and people don't slow down.
And I think that if we had an opportunity for people
to take a step back,
especially in traumatic moments,
through and organized, you know, through school
where they're like, let's stop
so you can process what's going on.
I think it would allow people
to then get to that intellectual place at a younger age
versus being older
because no one allowed me to stop.
So I felt like I had to continue to run.
I felt like I continue to have to fight
because of the fact that I was like, if I stop, they win.
When actually, if I would've stopped sooner,
I would have healed quicker.
I would've won.
Because I would have more understanding that
this is your shit.
This is not my shit.
You know what I mean?
(percussive music)
Okay, let's get back into it with Courtney Dauwalter,
the world's best female ultra runner.
And when it comes to races, 200 miles and longer,
arguably the best period,
humble master of grit and boundary,
busting physical prowess.
Courtney joined me on episode 618
to share the mindset techniques and tactics
that have propelled her superhuman accomplishments.
Here's a peak into our conversation.
Let's go a little bit deeper.
Tell me, tell me a little bit more about
what that is when you reach that point or that limit,
or that place where you feel like
you can't put one foot in front of the other,
like, what is the, what is the,
like the lesson that you find for yourself in that?
So I call it the pain cave, that place.
And I guess like probably four or five years ago,
I viewed the pain cave
as like this place that you should try
to put off as long as possible in a race,
like make your pain cave be as far away from you as you can.
And if you arrive to it,
then you just sit in it
and you try and survive the pain cave.
But in the past couple of years, I mean,
it's just a mindset, right.
It's like all in our heads, this thing,
and in the past couple of years,
it's been the place I want to get to.
So like changing it to a place
where I get to celebrate that I made it there.
And then that's where the work actually happens.
So making the pain cave bigger
is how I view it instead of like pushing the pain cave away.
And I think, I mean, our minds are so powerful.
So even just like changing the storyline
makes it a whole different game.
Right.
So what is the story that you like,
what is the script that you flip when you're,
when you're in that headspace and it's getting really hard?
Yeah, it's like, perfect.
This is what we wanted.
Now we get to actually do the hard work
of making the cave bigger.
And so it's like picturing a chisel
and just like making tunnels in my pain cave in my brain.
You actually visualize that?
Yeah.
I'm super visual.
Yeah, yeah.
I like that.
It makes it very visceral and real, if you can,
it's not just a mantra and mantras are great.
I'm sure you have mantras,
but actually creating that three-dimensional image
in your mind.
Yeah.
Yeah, and all, I mean,
it's just telling myself a different story
about that place where it hurts so bad, you know,
where before it was like surviving it
and now it's like, this is so cool we made it here.
And now we, we work.
Yeah.
As somebody who's out there pushing the envelope
in your sport,
showing the rest of us
what's possible
and breaking all these boundaries and barriers,
how does that affect your mental disposition
and how you approach other facets of your life?
Like how does it spill over
and how you think about possibilities and potential
in areas that are outside of running?
I think it's possible in every area outside of running.
I'm not like seeking it in any other area right now,
but I think what it's shown me is that like,
people are selling themselves short
and setting their bars too low
of what they could actually do
if they went all in on something, you know,
whatever they're psyched about
to just see what happens if they
invest a little more time and energy into it.
And what about for yourself?
For myself?
See, you deflected a little bit there.
What, never.
Because I was asking you
about you too.
I never do that.
Yeah.
I know.
(laughs)
Like, am I pursuing.
Am I?
Well, right now you're all in on running, right?
This is a hundred per,
110% all your focus and all your time,
but there are other interests I'm sure that you have,
and you're married and you have a relationship.
And I'm sure there's other goals
that maybe you're thinking about for your life after running
or in conjunction with your running.
Talk a little bit about that
and how you kind of see your life unfolding.
I don't know how I see it unfolding.
Because you're just, you're right where your feet are.
Yeah.
What I know is--
You wake up in the morning and decide.
Yeah.
I am having, like,
I love this chapter that it's in right now.
And so just enjoying that fully
and knowing like chapters don't go on forever.
So this ride, you know,
will end at some point and what comes next, I'm not sure,
but I hope whatever page it flips to next,
I can be just as excited about finding out what's possible.
Right.
Punk rock icon, spiritual warrior,
Bhakti yoga devotee
and former monk, Raghunath Cappo
graced the pod back on episode 583,
dropping many a pearl on
finding meaning beyond the ego,
transcending the illusions that hold us back,
and what it really means to be a spiritual being
having a human experience.
When you go to the ashram and you start living as a monk,
what is the teaching like?
And what is,
what is the day to day existence where you start to,
you know, intuit these teachings
and put them into practice?
Well, there's a, there's a lot to share.
I'm working on a book right now
that extracted six, very powerful principles
that I taught from the teachings.
And the first one is,
and these are based on the teachings of Chaitanya Mahaprabhu
who was a great,
considered by some, as a child prodigy,
because he was a child prodigy in Sanskrit.
Other people that knew more intimately thought of,
he was a mystic cause he did,
he performed so many mystical things, Christ-like mysticism.
And then, but his intimate followers
who are great gurus in their own right,
they considered him an avatar.
So his teachings were very simple,
and one of him is very basic.
And it's a great takeaway.
If you want to take away anything from today,
you can take this away.
Stop criticizing other people.
Like that, the sound coming out of your mouth
can be toxic.
And that was a powerful thing.
Stop criticizing.
I realized I'm living with so much criticism in my mind.
That doesn't mean we should throw discernment out.
We need discernment.
But the condemning language that happens on a regular basis
from finding fault with other people
and how you would do things so much better
if you were doing them.
Cut it out.
Stop letting that pour out of your mouth.
That was, that's a big one.
If you want, I'll just run through these.
Yeah, let's do it.
No, this is great.
That's one.
First of all, when did this guy live?
1400, the same time Columbus was showing up here.
Right.
This person, Chaitanya Mahaprabhu,
was in Bengal and traveled throughout India and Korea.
And basically he was a,
it was a Renaissance of Bhakti.
Bhakti means,
Bhakti yoga means connecting to source through love.
That's all the word really means.
And so a lot of the practices are singing,
are cooking, are meditation,
but everything is an action,
whether you're acting in a loving way
and dealing with other people.
And so, so yeah,
this is one of the teachings, I call.
The book is called "The Six Pillars of Bhakti."
And so one is not criticizing.
The second one is being tolerant.
Whereas criticism deals with, with other people,
another one is just dealing with life situation
and stop blaming the world for your unhappiness.
And this is very powerful.
It's transformational.
Even if you're a materialist,
this main teaching can transform your life.
But if you want it really experience
like the higher echelons of meditation, it's gotta be there.
Criticism, tolerance.
And this isn't a huge one, that number three.
And if you can add this one to your life,
it will, it's a such a game changer.
It's I take no offense,
meaning I will not be offended on a regular basis.
And that's a very common thing.
Sometimes we could see somebody talking over there
and I get offended.
I think they're talking about me.
So without provocation,
I think someone's got something against me.
And sometimes we'll walk around
holding some resentment for a person
who didn't even mean anything.
And that gets split in two things
because sometimes people don't mean anything,
but due to my, some proclivity that I have,
that I don't trust the world,
that I take an offense
and I carry that resentment around with me
and it becomes a burden.
But sometimes people have hurt me,
they've actually deliberately hurt me,
but still that desire
or that need to forgive has to be there
because in the, in the, in the,
in the Bhakti culture is nothing's actually happening to me,
it's happening for me,
that there is a benevolent energy
lifting us higher and higher and higher.
And we have to,
and we have to see that everything is for my edification,
for my purification,
and sometimes even tragic things.
And so there's a firm faith
that everything's happening for me.
And that we shouldn't be,
we shouldn't be heartless
when it comes to someone else's suffering.
I should see, okay, he's having a hard time.
We should feel like I have to reach out to that person.
They're having a hard time.
But for my own situation,
I should feel like, you know,
I'm going through a hard time
and this must be for my benefit.
What is that benefit?
And I can look at it.
I can at life like that.
So we don't hold any resentment.
We don't criticize.
We're tolerant.
Next one, we see the good in others and we let them know it.
Find good.
And this is where we're talking about,
instead of finding what this person is doing so wrong,
what are they doing right?
Why are they good?
This is such a powerful practice in this day and age,
because otherwise we're going to lock in
and we're just going to foster hate with others.
And you're going to have no commonality whatsoever.
What do we have in common?
What is right about this person?
And it's such a great thing.
Truthfully, it's a, it's a, it's a marriage saver.
It's a relationship saver.
You know, what is good about this person?
And then sharing it with them,
tell them why I appreciate you.
And that lack of appreciation can really kill.
It can kill love quick.
I mean, isn't that what romances is,
is full 100% appreciation for that person.
Right.
And the,
the piece, the second piece
about letting that person know is, is crazy powerful.
Right.
And it's something
that most of us don't do nearly enough of.
Yeah, I mean, we might have a person
that would do anything for us.
They would come anywhere at any time at any moment.
Hey, I need your help.
Can you come here?
Yeah.
That person, I never let them know
how much I appreciate them.
Sometimes the people that are the closest to us,
we never share with them how much we appreciate it.
The next one was quick to apologize.
If you feel like you hurt someone's feeling,
if you're a little obtuse and you,
you apologize first you say, hey, I'm sorry.
I don't know if that offended you,
but please forgive me if it did.
A big game changer.
And another one is we keep a tally
of how we, of how we are blessed.
We keep a list of how fortunate we are.
A gratitude practice, basically.
What's that?
A gratitude practice.
And sometimes people don't have a gratitude,
gratitude practice.
They have a, this is unfair practice.
This is an entitlement practice.
And the problem with that is it's, it's simple math.
Entitlement makes you sad.
Gratitude makes you happy.
At the ripe age of 16,
after qualifying for the Olympic trials,
pro runner Mary Cain was quickly establishing herself
as the fastest girl in a generation,
until that is she joined Nike's elite Oregon project team
run by infamous coach, Alberto Salazar.
After suffering immensely
under Salazar's abusive coaching system,
Mary bravely exposed at all in a New York Times video op-ed
entitled, I was the fastest girl in America
until I joined Nike.
Now an advocate resolute on creating positive change
for the next generation of female athletes,
Mary joined me on episode 611
to share ways in which we can all work
to fix women's sports.
This whole situation has made me
like, and this is, this is bad.
This is something I'm working on with my therapist,
but like less trusting.
And it's made me like more skeptical of authority.
And it's made me question--
Sure.
Like society's behavior in a way
that I just never had done before.
And I think that's really powerful.
And I think that's a great thing.
But in that moment,
it's like really horrifying to be like, oh my God,
like this, this was condoned.
This was normalized.
People acted like this was okay.
And I'm realizing right now how bad this was.
And like, who am I kind of in this big world
to like,
have figured it out?
And I think knowing that I did,
it was like,
you know, 24 hours ago, I didn't.
And like, that person almost scared me.
And I was like, I need to help them.
And obviously I couldn't go back in time and help myself.
So how can I pass it forward to the next person?
You know, it was like my immediate reaction.
And I remember I pulled my parents aside,
like maybe the next day, or like really early on in this.
And like I had, you know, I was like,
I have to tell you everything.
And like, we did the deep dive and we went like,
this was like an hour as long conversation
of me just sharing everything.
And as soon, like, you know,
there's obviously a lot of tears.
I can't even get through a podcast without crying.
And at the end,
like my parents' question was like,
what are you going to do?
And I said, and I don't know why.
I think I'm gonna start crying.
But I was like, I don't think
I'm ever going to be a pro runner again,
but I love this sport
and nobody's ever gonna sign me.
Nobody's ever gonna follow me again.
I said, but I can't live with myself
if I don't share this.
And if I don't like help that one person.
And I remember like, they were so scared for me,
and
so proud of me at the same time.
I think for them, it was just like,
like, it was almost like this happy proud, and this, like,
you're doing something bigger than yourself.
And again, we didn't think anybody would watch the video.
I thought if, if anything,
I'm going to be very honest when I say this,
having so many people watch that protected me
in a way that I don't know do people understand.
And had that been something
where like a couple thousand people watched it,
like the same negativity from one side of that conversation
would have been louder
and it probably would have been stronger.
And you see it in how other athletes from that program
has since been treated when they left
and when they came forward and when they were vocal.
And in many ways, like,
that's what I thought I was going to experience.
I mean, Kara Goucher has gotten death threats.
You know, athletes have been called
horrible things across like websites, social media.
They've been gaslighted.
And I just, I was prepared for that.
That was what I was signing up for.
And, you know, the sport is one in which again,
like
what, what was done was really horrible.
And yet, like a lot of the competitors
of these organizations
don't necessarily turn around and say like, oh, wow,
like you're really trying to do something good in the world.
Like, let's, you know, like support you,
if anything in the traditional space,
it's much more like, no, you're not that fast anymore.
Like whatever.
Yeah.
And everybody's running to protect their own
at the same time.
I mean, it is a David and Goliath story.
It's not just, Hey, this is Mary Cain.
And she's going to share her story, you know,
of how hard it was.
This is you basically taking on Nike.
I mean, it's, you know, that's a very,
and you're a young person.
Like that's very scary
and you still want to have this career in running.
So you're going to become,
you're risking becoming persona non grata in doing this.
And that takes like an unbelievable amount of courage.
And I think it's also like important for me
as I'm going and embarking on this
new endeavor and creating a team and
almost like learning,
like it's important to learn what not to do, right.
That's, that's,
I have a lot of experience with what not to do,
but I think the other thing is that as much as that's good,
you know, you have to learn what to do
and you can't almost only be coming into
this like beautiful journey of creating a team
that I'm embarking on with like a cynical perspective,
which I think would be really, really easy for me to do,
if I'm honest.
And so there's so much importance.
To fuck all those Nike guys team.
Yes, exactly.
That's the name of the team.
Pretty much.
It's like really important for me to like,
think about like
so many people who've helped me
and so many people who supported me through that time,
like the Alexi's,
or people who just,
like the Wes' who stepped up and said like, I'm here for you
because those are the people who I can lean on
and learn from
when creating something beautiful
versus just kind of creating something out of a fear
of what was, you know.
When you, when you look on the past,
it can't ever be like,
I'm just trying to rewrite my own story.
It's how can I really make something good going forward?
The voice, the profit of all things action sports,
Selema Masekela is among many things
about a surfer,
a snowboarder, a skater,
and the beloved host of the ESPN X Games.
On episode 594, we dove into his fascinating life story.
We dug into the ways sport holds the power
to break outdated paradigms
and the progress many industries need to make
to be truly accessible and equal to all.
Moved to Carlsbad.
And, you know, we wake up in the morning
and you're in this place,
like when we drove in that night, in the U-Haul,
and then that next morning you wake up,
walk out the front door,
it smells different.
I never smelled this before.
And look up and like,
it feel this, this air feels different.
Palm trees swaying.
And I remember looking, panning rights slowly,
and I recognize that we're on a hill
and about two miles away,
a mile or two away is the ocean.
And I'm like, huh, okay.
I still don't, there's no point of reference about surfing.
I'm just taking in where we're at.
And like, literally in that moment,
as we're unloading the, the U-Haul my,
my stepfather and I,
like a kid comes driving by in a purple Honda revo scooter
with a full waterfall haircut,
a tank top t-shirt,
board shorts,
sandals, and a book bag between his legs.
And I'm like, what, what is that?
What kind of alien?
What I, I literally was an alien,
and in my mind is like, is he?
He's going to school?
What?
And a couple days later
I go enroll in this school and everyone's dressed like that.
And I'm like, in literally like
in like Timberland boots, jeans,
I've looked like I've come from another planet.
Everyone's speaking in this weird dialect and said,
you know, dude, and bro, and brah.
And you're like Run DMC and they're Spicoli.
Yeah, exactly.
And I met some cool kids at,
when we went to church.
My stepfather, my mother was genius.
She was like, sure, we'll do your Spanish thing eventually,
but we're starting in English.
She also had no intention
to ever--
She's crafty.
She, my mother's crafty, super crafty.
She was like, all right, sure.
But also like the,
the compromised part was like
her alternative medicine crew was,
was like running heavy in So Cal,
like she could be amongst her people and not be a weird.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, North County, San Diego,
she's right where she wants to be.
Right where she wants to be.
And she bought a store, a site unseen,
a business from a woman who was in,
worked with like one of the same herbs companies that she,
she dealt with.
And that was,
we were supposed to be moving to a place
that had a storefront.
It turns out that the storefront was literally
the garage of this woman's house
in a cul-de-sac on a hill
that had literally no foot traffic at all.
And there's no like Instagram to promote your business.
And it was like, oh,
well this, this is different.
My mom, you know, realize like, oh,
I'm going to have to build up a whole clientele.
And it was a whole thing.
And shout out to my stepfather, you know,
for as much as we had a lot of,
a lot of shit that like, you know,
was a challenging relationship on many levels,
he didn't have work.
And he went out and became a day laborer
to like help make shit work.
Like he was out working construction, you know,
on construction sites, you know,
making whatever, $15 an hour.
And like, pretending like everything was good.
That's rough.
But it was rough before he was able
to like establish his thing.
And he started a pest control business,
'cause that's what he did back east.
But these kids that I met at church went to my high school
and it turns out they were all surfers.
And a couple of them were like, def,
they weren't like super holy.
They were like, we're cool.
And this kid, Justin,
he invited me to lunch the next day at school.
And I was so stoked to meet some, some kids that were cool.
And you could leave campus
to go, to, to go to lunch,
which I had never experienced before in the east.
Like we go to school,
you're in prison until it's time to get out.
And we went to this beach parking lot
after we'd gotten food at a,
at a place called Carl's Junior that I didn't know existed.
And we're sitting in the car in the back of his, I mean,
I'm in the, in the trunk of his Subaru hatchback with,
in the cars, packed with everybody,
like, you know, eating
and they're looking out in the lineup and I look up,
I'm like, ah, no way.
Surfing.
And these guys are speaking in the language,
talking about what they're seeing waves and swell.
And I'm just sitting there quiet,
like what, I'm flashing back to a year ago in Bondai.
And I was like, hey, I've seen this before.
And they're like, whatever dude.
I'm like no,
I was in Australia last year at Bondai beach.
And they're like, now what.
Yeah.
(laughs)
Pre-internet, pre,
like Bondai beach must've been like Oz.
Yeah.
I've seen it in magazines and movies.
And also mind you, there's like couple of--
Least likely guys never
they ever imagined.
There's two other black kids in the school.
One runs track and the other one
plays football and I've shown up.
And they're like, what are you talking about?
And then I'd tell him my story.
And like Paul Simon, my dad,
it's like, who, what?
Who are you?
Like, I'm like, I want to do that.
Like I saw this.
And I was like, if I ever get a chance,
I told Justin like, I want to, I want to try it.
And he's like, all right.
Be at my house on Saturday.
And that's how I got to experience surfing.
We went there and they had a wetsuit and board for me and
put the wetsuit on backwards.
Everyone laughed and--
Right.
I finally made it.
You ended up surfing like 170 days in a row, right
without missing a day.
Yeah.
I, surfed.
So there's a, you are committed to figure this out.
The first time I stood up was like for five seconds.
And it was literally like,
I had gone to church thousands of times, you know,
prayed in groups in large conventions.
And, and in,
in know, I, you know, three different religious meetings,
I never ever felt spirituality before.
I'd never felt a soul calling
like I did at 16 and a half,
standing on a surf board for like five seconds.
Time stopped,
everything changed.
It literally felt like whatever,
some spirit poured into me.
And when I came up after falling,
I screamed as loud as I could.
And my whole life just pivoted.
And it was like, okay, this is everything now.
And I'd never, it was--
You had that clarity.
I had that clarity.
It was the greatest spiritual awakening
that I could have ever asked for at the time.
Yeah, I mean, we could talk for
two hours about the spirituality of surfing,
but what's interesting is that
it was etched in your soul in a way
that almost makes it sound like
some kind of past life thing.
Like when you have that experience in Bondai
and then when you actually connected with it.
I mean, first of all, you have,
you have that experience of Bondai
and there's a knowingness
about your path on some conscious/unconscious level.
Then the universe conspires to move you to, you know,
the epic surf spot in America.
Like completely, I mean, nobody could have predicted
a set of circumstances that would bring that about,
and then the manner in which you just go all in on it
from the outset, like it's wild.
In retrospect, yeah.
You know.
Yeah.
I mean, it, it just was, it just clicked.
It was like, oh, this is me,
everything associated with this.
I need, I need to just soak.
I would go to the library
at school and read back issues of surfer magazine.
Like I had to learn the culture, the origins, everything.
And
as you're coming of age
and you're dealing with all the challenges
of your teen angst and then the extra layers of
that were particular to my family,
but every kid had a version of it,
surfing became this mega oasis
for like none of that mattering,
like the ultimate freedom of, of expression,
of like that was the one place
that I could express myself, wholly
that I couldn't do with my mom and stepdad.
And I couldn't even do with my dad.
Like surfing literally was that place
where I could just express,
even though I had the tensions of
a community that thought they were the definition
of the thing
and that they were allowing me to,
to visit in their space.
And people, many times feeling uninhibited to tell me
that I shouldn't be out there
and using the N word, et cetera, et cetera.
None of that could actually get in the way of the thing.
Like when I stood up to do the thing,
there was no voices except that.
Wow.
Point blank.
Maggie Q is the hero we all need.
Actress, activist,
fashion designer, and plant-based icon,
Maggie is best known for her roles in action films,
like "Mission Impossible" and the "Divergent" films,
performing her own stunts on screen
and advocating for animal rights offscreen.
In episode 596, Maggie taught us
the importance of finding your cause
and giving you're all fighting for it.
Here's a clip from that empowering exchange.
I mean, I work, you know, with a group.
I'm on the board of a group
called Social Compassion in Legislation.
We do a lot of legislative work up in Sacramento and,
you know, it's that it is the epitome of that, right.
So you sort of like, you know,
you're going into these meetings with these senators
and assemblymen and people who can, you know,
these are lawmakers, these are people that,
that really essentially work for us, right.
And you know, I go there and I'm, you know,
sort of lobbying senators and you know,
in this building and,
and then there's no one there.
And I'm driving down Melrose
and there's 40 people in line for lip gloss.
And it, it bums me out because it's like,
we have so much influence, you know,
all you have to do is care.
All you have to do is show up.
Half of it's showing up, right.
Life, gotta show up.
And then once you show up, you know, you,
you really have to like be in those rooms with people
that you, that that may not get it.
But what you're going to do in those rooms
can be pretty remarkable.
Yeah.
Well it's one thing to be
a proponent of this lifestyle.
And it's another thing to really shoulder
that mantle and carry that responsibility to use,
like the platform that you have to,
to advocate, you know,
on behalf of these causes.
So where does that come from in you?
Because it would be very easy for you to be like,
I'm just, I'm doing my movies.
I don't want to make waves.
Sure.
It is much easier to do that.
Yeah.
I know, I know it, trust.
Where does that pull come from?
I kind of feel like
it's almost not even a choice in that, you know,
we live this very privileged existence,
like in every way, right.
And I mean that in things that I've earned.
I mean it, and things that I'm living like, okay,
I'm given my health,
I have this gift of health and I can walk and I function.
So that's a gift.
And then I've earned these other things
where I work in Hollywood and I have certain privileges.
And, and you know, you,
you start to develop a voice for certain things
and it doesn't feel like a choice.
It feels like a responsibility,
you know, doesn't it,
when you sort of, when you have a lot, how do you not?
And it can be anything, you know,
pick what it is that you sort of feel
isn't right in your mind, in your heart and your soul.
And you go out there and you really, you,
you fight for it.
And you hope that other people will do the same
when something matters to them,
because I'm sure you get this all the time.
I've gotten it for 20 years.
Like, oh, you don't care about kids.
You don't care about women.
You don't care about, you know, libraries.
I don't know.
Because you've chosen to advocate for one thing.
That's at the exclusion of other things that are important.
That's exactly it.
I'm like, you're so right.
I hate children because I love the environment
or whatever it is, you know.
And it sort of is there's always this line.
And so it's always this thing of like, you know,
I have people that write into me and go,
you care more about homeless pets
than you do about homeless children.
I'm like interesting.
And I said,
I'm so glad that you care about homeless children.
Well, I do.
I said, well, tell me more.
What do you, what do you do for homeless children?
I'm fascinated.
I want to know.
Nothing.
Crickets.
Absolutely nothing.
So I've never ever run into a person
who puts themselves out there,
who advocates for something they care about,
regardless of what it is, who has ever criticized me.
You know.
And I'm in rooms with women's rights activists,
my human rights friends in DC,
we all kind of look at each other and go,
thank you for what you do,
because what you do matters in your lane
and in your category.
It's always people who do nothing who have a ton to say
about what you're doing.
So going into this industry,
I did have this work ethic that was kind of built in.
I have parents who work very hard.
And then, and then Jackie, right?
And so you're,
I'm surrounded by these people where it's like,
you have to earn your way.
There's no free lunch here.
There's no, like, you know,
relying on, you know, your,
your God-given skill set or looks or any of this stuff,
you have to work hard.
So, okay.
So I had that.
And it was like, almost like emotional cutting.
It was like very punishing the way I went about things
and like, okay, I'm just gonna work super hard.
But I never felt like I had,
I had really gotten there.
I had earned it.
I was, I was really worth much.
I never felt that way.
And that that's a problem, right.
Because no matter what you're achieving,
you still, it's,
it's never enough,
but not in an obsessive way,
in an internal kind of sad way.
And so it wasn't until we were actually in Rome,
I think it was our first day of filming.
We were on the Tiber River.
We're speeding up and Tom.
Speed boat stuff.
Yeah, Tom does everything, right.
So he's manning the boat,
I mean he's the whole thing.
And so we had a guy like kind of crouched on the bottom.
If we have, of course,
we had some like electrical failure or something, right.
But he wasn't doing.
Tom was doing everything.
So it was me, it was the team, right.
It was Tom, myself, Ving Rhames,
and Johnny Rhys Meyers during this boat.
And we have, you know,
they're changing a lens or something, right.
So we're at our ones
and we're just sitting there in this boat.
And there's, it was so intimidating
'cause there was maybe 5,000 people that had lined
just to get a glimpse of him.
Lined up on the side of the river.
Oh, I mean, as far as the eye could see, and you're like,
holy shit, I'm standing next to a movie star.
This is a movie star, like legit.
Like there's no question,
this man, like the power that he holds.
I mean, just a glimpse of him.
Like they were, it was crazy.
So anyway, I'm sitting in this boat and it, you know,
it's really intimidating day.
Although I felt sort of like,
no, I felt good about it and it was fine.
And we're sitting in the boat and Tom's like,
Maggie, tell me about your life.
Like, I haven't seen any of your US movies.
And,
and I was like, I don't have any US movies.
He's like what.
Yeah, and he goes--
They cast you?
He's like, I don't understand.
What do you mean?
And I said, oh,
this is,
this is my first US movie.
And his face, he goes, you're kidding me.
And I said, no, no, this is my first US movie.
And he's like, I don't believe this.
There's no way.
He's like Ving,
and Ving's like on his phone or something,
he's like, Ving, get over here, get over here.
And Ving's like, hey, what's going on.
And he goes, ah,
this is Maggie's first US movie.
And Ving goes, no shit.
And I'm like, yeah.
And he's like, damn.
He's like Johnny, Johnny, you believe this.
And he brings Johnny over,
it's like so embarrassing.
So Johnny comes over and he's like,
Johnny, this is Maggie's first US movie.
And Johnny's like really, no way, blah, blah.
You know, so everybody's like having this conversation
about me in front of me.
And I'm like, yeah, that's it.
And Tom's like, let me get this straight.
Let me get this straight.
You have not done a movie in the US
and then the first movie you do
is like a $200 million like monstrosity
where we're like on the Tiber River in Rome
speeding up and down with this 200 man crew,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
This is your first experience?
I said, yeah, that's right.
And he goes,
you know, Maggie, if you didn't tell me that,
he goes, I would never know it.
He's like, you act like you belong here.
And I don't know where it came from.
I looked at him and I said, I do belong here.
And he looked at me and he said,
you're goddamn right you do.
That's fucking cool.
(laughs)
Like that's a moment.
It was.
It was really like,
I can't believe I just said that to him.
I got chills--
I'm like where did that even come from?
Like, I don't have the confidence say that,
but I know that I put in years of blood, sweat and tears,
literally, by the way.
And, and I was there and I'm like, well, screw it.
Like, why, why shouldn't I be here?
But, that is not to say that,
that I took it for granted
where I thought I was like special and like,
oh, it had to be me.
No, I, by the way, like,
I don't care who it is,
it can always be someone else.
It doesn't have to be you.
It doesn't have to be me.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
So it's keeping that in mind, I think,
that keeps it all into perspective
for me in Hollywood.
Right, that's such a good story.
As a plant-based endurance athlete,
it's probably no surprise that the question
I get asked most frequently is
where do you get your protein?
Well, to help me dive into the nuances
of this understandable inquiry,
Matt Frazier and Robert Cheeke,
authors of the aptly titled book,
"The Plant-Based Athlete"
joined me to break down the basics
of optimizing athleticism
from strength training to endurance
all on the power of plants.
Here are a few of their thoughts on plant-based performance
lifted from episode 608.
More than likely,
this is the trick to becoming a great athlete.
Like that's not really what this is about.
It turns out that it is that for the right person.
And there are lots of people who,
including all of us, I think,
who kind of experienced
our, the most success we had athletically
once we went plant-based.
But for me, it's more that like, you can do this
and you can get all these great benefits of
the longevity really, and health span.
To me, that's what it's all about.
I mean, I just think, you know,
you mentioned like the omnivorous diet,
like what's wrong with this.
This is natural.
But natural doesn't really affect,
it doesn't really get into health, right.
Nature selects for reaching reproductive age
and a few years past to raise your kids,
but it's not really about what gets you to 80, 90 and,
and keep moving and being healthy
because that doesn't matter for,
for natural selection.
So to me, that's like where we should think about like,
not like what is,
and I don't honestly know what is the most natural diet
or whatever that even means,
but which one is the data saying is keeping people,
giving them the longest health, health span,
keeping them mobile and happy and active and,
and healthy and alive.
And it looks a lot to me,
like that's the plant-based diet that,
that seems to be where the science
is all pointing these days.
Right, right.
You're your on-ramp, Robert, was ethics.
Matt, yours was more health-related.
Mine was vanity,
vanity and health and athletic performance ultimately.
But what's so amazing and beautiful
about how this movement is blossomed
is that now there are all these on-ramps
from the ethical considerations, of course,
to sustainability,
to climate change concerns,
environmentally sensitive,
you know, which we all should be, of course,
and the longevity health considerations
of the foods that we eat.
And now with this book,
"Plant-Based Athletic Performance."
And I think it's so great
because just like all the athletes profiled in your book,
different people connect with and,
and resonate with different individuals, right.
So not everybody is going to
cotton onto the ethical argument,
but perhaps they're concerned about the environment
and the way that I look at it,
as I look at it as this umbrella lifestyle
that checks every single box.
Like you can opt out of the chronic lifestyle illnesses
that are unnecessarily killing millions of people.
Obesity rates right now are through the roof.
Diabetes, it's predicted something like 50% of Americans
are going to be diabetic by 2030.
All of these chronic illnesses are lifestyle illnesses
directly correlated to the foods that we're eating.
Meanwhile, we're decimating the planet
because animal agriculture just requires too many inputs,
too much land, too many resources
for us to sustainably produce enough animal products
for the planet to eat.
As we, you know,
careen down this path towards 10 billion people
living on this planet.
But the fact that, you know,
the truth is most people are walking around
thinking about themselves.
They're like, that's fine.
But like, I just want to be buffed
and I want to eat what I want to eat.
And I want to be able to kill it in the gym or,
you know, qualify for Boston or whatever it is.
And the truth is is that all of those goals
are not just possible,
but more possible by dent of
learning what you guys have laid out in this book.
When, when you read the stories,
one of the things you'll notice
is that what brought people to a plant-based diet
in the first place.
For many people, it's inflammation,
it's pain that they feel even as a young person.
Like take David Carter,
NFL lineman, I mean a completely star athlete
in his 20s.
And he can barely push himself out of a bathtub
because his joints hurt so badly.
And this is a guy who's supposed to be in his prime,
he's playing in the NFL.
And then when he went to a plant-based diet,
not only did he drop weight,
which helped him get rid of some body fat,
and then which he later added the weight back on
with more muscle,
he got faster, he got stronger,
but the pain went away.
I mean, the pain just went away.
And his career lasted slightly longer
than the average NFL career.
And he's been, you know,
in incredible shape since then too,
I've seen him in his retirement.
He looks fantastic.
And you look at other athletes,
national champion cyclists
who had inflammation in their knees.
And at age 19, you know, had pain that,
that made their career suffer to some degree.
And then a plant-based diet eradicated that,
and they were able to perform
and then become champions and all these different levels.
And I know, you know, Fiona Oakes is someone you know,
and have talked to.
I mean she didn't have a,
a knee cap in her right knee,
and wasn't even supposed to walk, or let alone run,
and went on to overcome that
and has been plant-based since age five or so,
vegan for nearly 50 years and,
and has gone on to set Guinness world records.
And when you look across the board,
men or women doesn't matter the sport.
So many people came to this lifestyle
to reduce inflammation,
improve recovery, and have better results.
And, and that's, and that's what they did.
And it's so fun to tell those stories.
There's also stories of people who
had all kinds of problems with addiction
and overcame that,
you know, like Dotsie Bausch is open about that.
And John Joseph, rough childhood.
You know, like these are,
these are inspirational.
And in a lot of ways, their success is aspirational.
And that's what,
I mean I get moved every time I read the book
because of those stories.
Just this past week,
have you guys been following the iron cowboy
who's trying to do these a hundred Ironmans in a row?
You're aware of this guy?
That was a couple of years ago.
No, he did.
Well, he did 50,
50 Ironmans in 50 states in 50 days.
But now he's in the midst
of trying to do this thing called conquer 100
where he's doing 100,
he goes out the front door of his house
and does an Ironman every day.
And he's on like day 72 right now or something like that.
Wow.
It's insane, right?
Like every single day doing an Ironman.
And he's had, you know, struggles that he's overcome.
Like he, and the whole thing is playing out
on Instagram stories.
And he'll, he's very transparent about his injuries
or what he's dealing with.
Like, this is no small fete.
Like this is a big deal.
But just the other day,
the reason I'm bringing this up is just the other day.
I think it was yesterday.
He switched up his diet like a week ago.
I've been trying to encourage this guy
to go plant-based for a long time.
And I've kinda, you know, he flirts with it,
but then you go, you know, whatever.
I don't know what he was eating,
you know, for the first 50 some odd of these Ironmans,
but he switched up his diet.
I can only suspect that it became
much more whole food based
and more plant forward or plant leaning.
I'm not going to say he went plant-based.
I know he didn't.
But I know that he started building into his daily routine,
a lot more whole foods.
And he said that he dropped five pounds of inflammation.
Like he felt he went,
and then the next four days,
he felt the best,
like through 68 to 72 of these Ironmans,
he said he felt the best that he had felt so far.
So my point being
that inflammation is not just a real thing.
Like that's a, that's a,
that's an extreme example of
the impact of the foods that you're eating
on your body's response to exercise induced stress
and how important it is.
So if you're looking to recover,
eating a plant centric diet,
plant-based diet is going to take you a long way towards,
towards, you know,
reducing that inflammation
that impedes your body's ability to repair itself
in between workouts.
And in turn, of course,
you know, will, will power youth through, you know,
bigger breakthroughs then you would have ordinarily
because that inflammation stunts your,
your body's to adapt and grow.
Yeah, that's like everyone always asks
what the mechanism is.
And like, why does a plant-based diets
supposedly so much better for sports
if you're claiming that it is,
and no one's ever really, you know, known,
we don't know what it is.
It's just, it seems like you stopped getting injured.
And, but Brendan Frazier back in the early 2000s was saying
that it was when he, when he experimented
with a bunch of diets back in high school,
he found that this was the one that let him recover fastest
and get back so he could get in, you know,
whatever 10 workouts in a week
when the competition could only get six
or something like that.
And so I think that's, that's a huge part of what you know,
of the story behind why plant-based diet
seems to be so good for sports
is that the anti-inflammatory compounds that are just
naturally part of it without even trying,
much as if you actually do try
and seek out the foods that that would maximize that.
It just allows you to get back out there faster
and be back out there 100% or very close to it,
rather than every time you come out,
you're a little bit worse
so that eventually an injury follows.
Former lawyer turned CNN legal analyst, Mel Robbins,
absolutely turntables in the RRP community.
One of the most widely booked public speakers in the world
with followers in the millions,
Mel drop by the studio to promote her new book,
"The High Five Habit,"
and basically just ignited a movement
of self-belief along the way.
Here's a peak into our conversation back on episode 630.
Well, let me tell you my intention for this conversation.
That you listening to us
have this podcast be that crack
that lets some light in
and becomes a sliding door that you might just see.
Oh, wow, maybe if that phone call I'm avoiding
or counting backwards,
five, four, three, two, one,
or high-fiving myself in the mirror,
even though I don't think I deserve it,
and I think it's stupid and I'm a failure,
and why is this going to help,
that you try it.
Yeah.
Because I think that any,
you can trace back again, back to our dots analogy.
Any change in trajectory was just a moment.
And for me, that moment was
when the alarm went off, I just counted backwards.
Like NASA launches a rocket,
five, four, three, two, one.
And I stood up and you know what my first
reaction to it was?
This is fucking stupid.
Correct.
Resignation.
Yeah.
It was immediately like,
okay, so you can get out of bed.
So fucking what,
you're $800,000 in debt, Mel.
How is this going to help?
And thankfully, I thought,
well, what the hell do I have to lose?
Why not just for one day,
any time Mel, you know what you should do,
but you don't feel like it,
or anytime your emotions start to hijack you,
or anytime you feel afraid or anxious or whatever,
why don't you just count backwards and see what happens?
And that's what I did.
Yeah.
And I haven't looked back.
I think the power of it,
because it is like on some level,
it really is fucking stupid.
Oh, totally.
And when I first saw you on Facebook or whatever,
before I knew you, and I was like, who is this?
What is this?
You can say the word, I don't care.
I can take it.
I was like, five, come one.
You know, this is a bunch of bullshit, right.
Now I've gotten to know you.
I adore you.
I love you.
I think you're brilliant and talented in so many ways,
but it took me a minute to get my head around this thing.
But I think where I'm at now with it
is that there's a certain genius in the simplicity
and the low hanging fruit nature of it.
Like I had to pick up a phone,
pick up a phone and make a very difficult phone call.
That phone weighs 1,000 pounds.
Yeah.
That's a, that's a heavy,
that's a, that's a leap, right?
But to say, well, I can count down from five to one, right?
I could, I could do that, at least.
Like it's creating permission
and a welcome mat and something that's so accessible
for anybody, no matter how much pain they're in
or whatever circumstances they might find themselves in.
So whether it's counting down from five to one
or giving yourself a high five in the mirror,
it may seem like childish or silly,
but in truth, there's a,
there's a neurochemical thing that takes place
that sets in motion a chain of events
that allow you to take that initial action.
And that then puts you in a position
to take further actions.
And that's where the cascading effect happens
and lives change.
Well, you said it earlier.
So let me hit you with the science.
Because the fact is I used it in secret for three years
to five, four, three, two, one pick up that phone
that weighed 1,000 pounds.
And part of the genius of this is that
when you start counting backwards,
you've already committed to taking action.
So the counting itself moves you
from a bias towards thinking
toward a bias toward action.
And the more you repeat it,
the more you break the pattern of thinking
and you program in a pattern of taking small actions,
it creates agile moves, an agile mindset.
So that's one thing.
The second thing that's crazy cool about this
is that the reason why it's so hard to change
is because you talk about changing
with the prefrontal cortex.
You're conscious when you sit in your therapist's chair,
or you're listening to me and Rich,
and you're using the think,
you're using this sort of strategic part of your brain.
The second that you're in a situation
where you're procrastinating
or you're thinking negative thoughts,
it's your subconscious that's in charge of you.
And so in order to change,
you have to interrupt subconscious patterns.
You see the five second rule
isn't just some dumb counting backwards thing.
It is a form of metacognition
that interrupts the pattern stored
in your subconscious brain.
Counting backwards requires you to focus,
which flips on your prefrontal cortex.
It gives you a moment of control
over you think and do next.
That's the genius of it.
And the reason why I'm so fucking passionate about this
is not only because kids can use it
and senior citizens can use it.
You don't have to have any kind of education
or speak any kind of language.
It works for anybody that uses it.
Is because I am now standing with millions of people
that have tried it.
And the,
we have pediatricians around the world that are using it
to help kids interrupt thoughts that trigger anxiety,
veterans organizations that are using
five, four, three, two, one
to help reprogram responses to triggers.
We had an entire wing
of a Pennsylvania psychiatric inpatient nursing unit
show up at the talk show to tell me
that of all of the tools
that they give people that have an inpatient commit,
the single most positive and effective tool
is the five second rule.
Because it is simple.
You remember it,
and it immediately interrupts
the negative and suicidal ideations that torture people.
And speaking of suicide, we know of 111 people
who have stopped themselves from taking their lives
by five, four, three, two, one,
asking for help.
So I am here to tell you,
I don't give a fuck how stupid you think this is.
I want you to try it.
I want you to share it with people
because interrupting the patterns of thought and behavior
that are holding you back
and pushing yourself to take action
or to think something different,
it is the only way you are going to change.
And this is a tool that's going to help you bridge that gap.
Boom.
I think it's safe to say
that there is no one quite like
the singular and the bold David Choe.
An icon and an artist in many different senses,
David is best known for his Vice special, "Thumbs Up"
as well as "The Choe Show" on FX.
But what interests me most about David
has nothing to do with his copious talents,
his wealth or his fame.
Instead, it's really just all about his honesty.
He has this rare, beautiful, and raw vulnerability
that is both sweet and endearing.
So here's a slice of his wildlife story lifted
from episode 626.
I've been to every type of 12 step meeting
and ones like, because I'll be in a city where, oh shit,
I can't find a gamblers, overeaters,
or sex and love addict
or whatever the addiction co-dependence I have.
You're Helena Bonham Carter in "Fight Club"--
Exactly.
Yeah.
And they're like, oh, there's only an AA meeting
or narcotics anonymous or marijuana anonymous.
So I'll go to that meeting
even though that's not my addiction.
And as I listened to thousands of people share their story,
I go, oh, it's all gambling.
Every addiction is gambling addiction.
Every single, when you drink and you get in a car,
you're like, I kind of don't care if I make it home or not.
Right, that's gambling.
When you're like having sex,
and you're like, I'm not going to wear a condom.
And you're like, oh, I might have a kid.
I might get AIDS.
I might, that's gambling.
And, and so
to go to my first gamblers anonymous meeting
after going to 400 AA meetings in Los Angeles,
I was, I was shocked because
AA meetings and drug and NA meetings
are kind of like parties in LA, right?
Like it's very social there.
Bright lights, a lot--
Especially in LA.
300 people to, you know,
they're celebrity speaker, you know,
it's when you go to a,
a sex addict meeting,
a gamblers addict meeting,
you know, the process ones, there's more shame.
Yeah, it's really fucking dark.
Yeah, it's darker.
There's a lot of shares that end with suicide attempts.
You know.
So I went to a GA meeting
and we went in a circle and every single share,
it was a small meeting.
It was like six people.
Every single person shared about
how they try to kill themselves.
And I've said this before,
it's the reason why they don't have balconies in Vegas,
because if they did,
there'd be someone jumping off every day.
One out of four gambling addicts kills themselves.
So people go, gambling, I don't understand.
It's like,
so I'm sitting at the meeting
and everyone's like telling how much money they've stolen
from their family or lied and manipulated people out of
so that they could keep gambling,
and getting that once a lotto scratcher,
the horse race, everything right.
And I'm scared to share,
cause it's going around the circle and it gets to me
and I'm like, I just won $3 million at the,
my last, you know.
That's so crazy.
And I feel exactly the same as you,
You just said,
you broke into a cars to steal a quarter
so you can get the next scratcher.
I'm sitting here telling you I have two rotting lobsters
in my, in my hotel room.
I'm having sex with all these prostitutes
and gambling with millions of dollars, winning,
handing like a hundred dollar bills to everyone I know.
And I feel exactly the same as you.
So I sat there and
I go,
how do I feel?
How did I feel when I won $3 million at the,
on my last trip, right?
And I'm playing a quarter million dollar hands of blackjack
in private private rooms, you know.
And at that point I felt very little, you know.
But like you went $3 million, it feels good,
but not that good because I was already rich.
When I lose $3 million,
and even better yet when I lose 30 million,
then that feels amazing, right.
That feels amazing.
So I think that was the disconnect with
trying to talk to people in my tribe who are addicts
and people who aren't addicts, right.
And it doesn't matter if you're an addict
or you're not an addict
because everyone knows an addict
or at least has one in their family.
So that's the thing when people go, I don't,
but I don't understand.
Why don't you stop drinking or why don't stop?
Why don't you stop the behavior?
It's like, I want to fucking lose, that's why.
Do you get it?
Do you understand now?
I don't want to win.
I'm happier when I'm losing.
I want to lose everything.
But that's even harder for somebody to understand
because you're not operating on a rational plane.
Right.
You know, you're trying to, you know,
numb the discomfort of your internal pain
while also seeking to feel something
that will make you feel alive.
And if winning's not going to do it,
losing certainly is going to.
To have--
It doesn't matter
what that feeling is,
as long as it's a feeling different from however you feel.
Right.
And so,
sorry, I got fired up there for a second.
Go ahead, no.
So that's hard to explain.
That's hard to understand.
Like wait, you know,
you're trying to wrap your non-addict brain around someone
who's doing everything they can to
run away from everything,
feel numb, feel nothing, feel everything.
And so everything was off, you know, I did,
I did like these expensive brain scans
to show that I had like frontal like,
like kind of temporary brain damage
from just like complete overstimulation.
Yeah, your dopamine must have been completely fucked up.
And so doctor's orders,
take a year off.
And I had to sit in that
and it's like, well.
When was that?
This was
seven years ago.
So is this like the bottom?
I had never hit a bottom,
which,
you know, when I asked you about the podcast
and you're like, it's good.
And there's the negative.
So one of the things that I've taught myself into being
a successful gambler was
it's the golden rule.
Get out while you're ahead.
Right.
It's like, how do you win at life?
Get out,
it's like,
I look at a guy like Conor McGregor,
like just loved and you know, just dude,
if he had just stopped
like three, four fights ago,
he would just be a legend forever.
And now he's starting to turn into the villain
and like, fuck, if he just got out while he's ahead.
And I think of, you know, a lot of people like that,
but you get addicted to the attention
or whatever, you know, whatever the thing is.
And if you don't, you know,
die at 27 and become that like glorified--
Right, and that's what I was playing for.
I was trying to die.
I was like, once I hit 30, I was like shit,
it was supposed to happen before that.
Now I'm 45.
So
the positives,
if I'm looking at the bright side of gambling,
it had taught me,
I taught myself through discipline and hard work,
how to get out while I was ahead.
Which is a very non-addict thing.
Oh right.
And I, and I was like, man,
I've been to jail
multiple times.
I've lost, you know, small fortunes.
I've, you know,
I had this, like,
I've always had this like kind of,
no matter how much I try to hurt myself, there was,
this is what it was.
I've always, ah.
Shit, I might start crying, talking about it,
but I've always, in my entire life
have valued
friends over everything, right.
So I've learned a lot.
Now I would have a lot of tools.
I've learned a lot of things in recovery, but I've,
I have like the same friends
that I've met when I was in third grade, you know,
since I was eight years old
and I would do anything for my friends.
And I know that they feel the same.
So I knew like girlfriends would come and go.
I knew things.
But I was like,
what is the one thing that I must,
cause you hear stories.
You're like, oh yeah,
we used to be friends in college
and you know, life happens.
And then you grow.
And I was like, no,
like things come and go.
The one thing that has to like stay constant
in my life is friendship.
So I nurtured those things.
I nurtured.
I made sure no matter what happened in my life,
I would take trips.
I would call.
And,
and when we say love,
we usually tend to refer to romantic relationships.
But for me, I was like, love.
Love is for me, like, man love,
me loving another man telling,
you know, calling a guy to tell him how much I love him.
And so that,
if I didn't have that,
I would be dead right now.
If I didn't,
I can tell you three stories right now,
where if I didn't have a guy in my life that was like,
we're not doing this Dave.
Like I would,
I would be dead right now.
So
that's the one.
And even in all the recovery places,
people were like, holy fuck, dude,
you're getting a letter every day from someone.
Like you have,
you have more friends than anyone.
And I said that, without that,
and I know that's not
in the 12 steps or certain things,
but like the most,
one of the most important things for,
for my life and my recovery is
these friendships are invaluable.
Spiritual psychologist,
historian, philosopher,
and the world's only rabbi with a black belt in jujitsu.
I cherish my time with Rabbi Mordecai Finley, PhD,
back on episode 614.
A deep dive into the teachings of moral philosophy,
spiritual psychology,
skepticism, and stoicism,
this exchange is appointment listening
for anyone grappling with life's biggest questions.
There is a definition of self
because when people identify
their ego, self, thoughts, feelings, and emotions
as the self,
I say, you know, there is such a larger self
that you're going to discover
and you want to get out of that prison
because you're observing the world through prison bars.
And if you think that's all there is,
you're going to stay in that cell.
But if you are willing to accept the fact
that there's actually a world.
This is not dissimilar to Plato's allegory of the cave.
If you actually want to break the shackles
and break out of those prison bars, there's a way,
I say.
And the way, the main way
you know you're living in that prison is suffering.
Right.
If you're suffering
or you're causing other people to suffer unnecessarily,
there's an indication that your,
that your identification of self is insufficient.
But there's a competing idea
that that suffering is serving that individual in some way.
Right?
Like attachment to that suffering
is playing a role in how this person navigates
throughout the world.
And when you come to them and say,
you got to let go of this.
And there's a,
there's a whole larger world available to you.
It's a, it's.
It is it's terrifying, right?
So unless somebody is in sufficient amount of pain,
getting them to transition out of that
is an uphill battle.
It really is.
So oftentimes when a person comes to me,
and I have several,
I call this wisdom counseling.
I have several methods depending on the person,
but let's say a person comes to me and says,
hey, rabbi, what's this all about?
Give me the big picture before I sign up.
So I'll say, all right,
I want you to give me
a theory of the good in your life,
every part of your life, your romantic connections,
children, work in a relatively precise,
as detailed as possible,
what you would like, what you would think,
what would you feel, what you would say,
how others would react to you as, as precise as possible.
I call this a relatively precise vision for your life.
If you could live optimally, what would it be like?
So it's not that I say you have to,
I want them to say I have to.
I don't have to say,
I say I'm not telling you to do anything,
but if you have a relatively detailed vision
that you know yourself
would lead to a life, a flourishing life,
the Greek idea of eudaimonia,
then the question is
what's the gap
and how do you close the gap?
If you want to close the gap, I'll help you.
I think it would be good to just end this with a few
thoughts for the person who's listening
or watching who is
tiptoeing around the idea of what it means to be
a spiritual being having a human experience,
is trying to reckon with finding a little bit more meaning
and purpose in their lives,
and doesn't have the vernacular
or the experience to really do this by themselves.
Like how do you?
Sure, I love the metaphor.
Yeah.
It's it's a very available metaphore,
a spiritual being having a human experience.
That what you said?
Uh huh.
But to mean that takes a tremendous amount of work
because you have to go to your spiritual center
and that is the most, and only real thing.
And getting to that spiritual center,
you know, to the,
to the place deep in the inner life,
where the love of God is flowing in through the fountain.
And you're standing right there in the fountain.
Okay, you're at the deepest part of the soul.
And you come up out of that
and you have one urge, which is to love other people.
And anything gets in the way of that,
you got to stop it.
And love life,
and create beauty.
So, so many things come from
rooting yourself into the deepest part of what I will call
the life of spirit,
which for me as a religious person,
is the interface between the,
the, you know, the mind of God
and the mind of the human being,
or the soul of the universe and the soul of the human being.
Now, when you get there,
it's not as if you have meaning,
meaning has you.
This is one thing I really believe deeply.
We like to say, I have meaning in my purpose in life,
but if you really feel it,
it arrives at you and grabs you by the lapels
and it owns you.
So I don't have meaning.
Meaning has me.
I don't have purpose.
Purpose has me.
It's claimed me,
you know, going back to this stoic sense.
So when you feel claimed by love, justice, truth and beauty,
that propels you,
now that we have claimed you,
here's what you must do.
So what happens is that deepest sense of being claimed
by the divine, I'm speaking as a religious person,
when God claims you in the garments of love,
justice, truth, and beauty,
and pushes you into life.
Well, now you know how to be a human.
And what you have to do is you have to be,
you have to live interfacing in the world,
propelled by the meaning and purpose that has claimed you
for me in the modalities
of love, justice, truth, and beauty,
but always go back
to that deep experience of the soul.
So it's a constant dialectic between,
you know, being present in the world
and being present to the soul,
present to the world, being present to the soul.
So the person who's hearing this and says, how do I do that?
You know, I would say,
think deep things, you know.
What is love?
What is beauty?
What is truth?
Just start taking your consciousness and drilling through
the block between the mind and the soul
and drill down.
I remember it happening to me.
When I thought, well, I have these holy words
and knowing that they had soul residents
and drilling down through that granite block,
and one time when I hit the water
and the water just float up,
that's what I tell people.
Yeah, that's beautiful.
I think there is a epidemic of people feeling
a desire for, but a lack that animating force.
And I think for those that lack it or are seeking it,
that was beautifully put,
this idea of it claiming you,
but in order to put yourself in a position to be so claimed,
you have to commit
to living an examined life
and understand that patience is going to be important
because it's not a, it's not a light switch.
The examined life.
You have to examine the contents of consciousness
and go to the deepest place you can, do it every day.
And that, you'll hit the waters,
you'll hit the living waters of the soul.
All right, we did it you guys,
our final guest.
Who better to close things out
then one of my most popular guests to date,
neuroscientist, Matthew Walker,
one of the world's leading authorities
on the science of sleeping.
Our conversation covered everything you need and,
and truly ever wanted to know about,
you guessed it, sleep.
All in all, this is life altering listening
that will completely reshape your relationship with slumber.
Here's a powerful clip from episode 600.
Sleep really is right up there with outer space
and the depths of the ocean in terms of its,
its mysteries, and you know, the,
the idea that we're just beginning to learn
what's actually going on.
And it's not a matter of,
I'm sure you get this question all the time.
Like, well, what's more important REM sleep
or non-REM sleep, or what,
you know, what's the, you know,
the sort of significance of being deprived
of one over the other,
but it's really the interplay of all of these things.
And the more complex you realize it to be,
it becomes impossible to consider
that it's not crucial to all facets of human health.
That's right.
And, you know, when we go back
to that evolutionary story of, of how,
you know, detrimental sleep is as a state, and it is.
Let's face it.
You know, if there were any stage of sleep
that were not important,
that mother nature could have come in and excised
and had you, you know,
doing all of these benefits of wakefulness (mumbles).
I'm quite sure she would have.
And what we've learned
is that every stage of sleep is important.
Different stages of sleep
perform different functions for the brain and body
at different times of night.
And so, yeah, I often get that question.
People will say, how can I get more deep sleep,
or how can I get more REM sleep?
And, you know, I often say, well,
why do you want more of that?
And they say, well, isn't that the good stuff?
And they're both absolutely critical.
Now I could make a scientific argument
that REM sleep could be a little bit more important
from a simple mortality state,
because there were studies done back in the 1980s with rats,
and they've actually never been replicated again.
Now I found them difficult to read.
I do research in humans.
I don't do animal research.
And I think they won't be replicated for good reason.
What they wanted to do is see if a lack of sleep
is deathly, is a lack of sleep fatal.
And they had three different flavors of the experiment.
In the first, they took rats
and they just deprive them of sleep,
you know, night and day after day,
night and day after day.
And what they found is that those rats died
within about 20 days.
So in other words,
rats will die as quickly from a lack of food
as they will from a lack of sleep.
That's how fundamental it is.
Then the two additional flavors of the experiment,
they selectively deprive them
of either just rapid eye movement sleep
so that they could get just non-REM
or they did the opposite.
They just deprived them of non-REM and gave them REM.
And firstly, both of those were fatal.
But what was interesting is that
the rats died from REM sleep deprivation
within about 30 to 40 days.
And they died from deep non-REM sleep deprivation
within about 50 or 60 days.
So if we want to sort of do a Coke Pepsi challenge
between sort of, you know, non-REM and REM,
which one wins out in the mortality battle,
it seems to be REM sleep.
And, and to me, that's interesting too.
I, if you'd asked me where I would place my bets,
I would've said non-REM.
The reason is because non-REM came first.
If you look during the sort of the time course
of evolution of across phylogeny,
non-REM sleep was the first sleep to emerge.
And it was only when we went
from reptiles, amphibians and fish.
And then there was that bifurcation
to birds and then mammals
did the evolution of REM sleep emerge.
So REM sleep is the new kid on the evolutionary block.
And furthermore, REM sleep evolved twice independently
in birds and mammals,
which I find is fascinating too.
So to come back to your point, I'm sorry, I'm drifting,
but all stages of sleep are critical.
No one stage of sleep you can do without,
without suffering detriment.
Right.
I think if I were to have something, a single sentence,
I would say that sleep is the single most effective thing
that we can do each day
to reset the health of our brain and our body.
That would be a beautiful place to end this,
but I just realized there's an important thing
we also didn't talk about
that I would like you to touch on quickly.
Yeah, of course.
Which is the, the,
you talked at the,
at the outset about
what happens when you get a flu shot
and you're sleep deprived.
We're still in the midst of this pandemic.
We're slowly emerging out of it,
but can you talk a little bit
about what you've learned about
sleep, COVID,
immunity and how people should be kind of thinking about
how their relationship with, with the virus?
Yeah, so let me,
I'll speak about sleep and immunity sort of more generally,
and then come on to sleep COVID
because sleep has changed in at least four different ways
because of COVID,
quantity, quality, timing, and dreaming.
So I'll try to mentally put those stickies
up on my cerebral wall so I come back to them.
But in terms of sleep and immunity,
there is a very intimate association
between your sleep health and your immune health.
Firstly, what we know is that individuals
who report sleeping less than seven hours a night
are almost three times more likely to become infected
by the rhino virus, which is the common cold.
Second we know from a prospective study in,
I think it was well over 30,000 women,
women sleeping five hours or less a night
are more than 60% more likely to develop pneumonia
across a five-year period,
which of course is a critical part
of the COVID mortality equation.
We've also mentioned that statistic about
if you're not getting sleep in the week before
you get your flu shot,
you can't produce the normal antibody response.
Do we know that that's the case for COVID yet?
No we don't.
But we're looking at that.
We also know it's the case for Hepatitis A,
Hepatitis B vaccination too.
So I think there's an interesting case to be made
that it could make a difference.
We also know that just as we mentioned before,
just one night of short sleep,
you know, just four hours,
we'll drop those critical anti-cancer fighting cells,
natural killer cells by 70%.
If that's true, then why,
what is sleep doing for our emotional health
and sleep provides us with that sort of sorry,
not emotional health, for our immune health.
It provides us two different benefits.
Firstly, it's during sleep,
and particularly during deep sleep,
where the body will be stimulated to produce
many more of those critical immune factors.
Even better, the sleep will actually increase
the sensitivity and the receptivity of your body
to those increased immune factors.
So you wake up the next morning
as a more robust immune individual.
Sleep will restock the weaponry in your immune arsenal.
So on that basis,
I think sleep has become very relevant in this pandemic.
I really hope you enjoyed this reflection in the rear view
and found these two episodes uplifting and inspiring.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for listening.
And of course I appreciate all the love and all the support.
The podcast is just been an absolutely amazing journey
and I'm just so grateful that you're on it with me.
And I look forward to growing and learning together
in the new year ahead.
If you'd like to support the show,
the easiest and most impactful thing you can do
is to simply subscribe to it on Apple podcasts,
on Spotify, and on YouTube.
Sharing the show or your favorite episode with friends
or on social media is of course always appreciated.
And finally, for podcast updates,
special offers on books,
the meal planner and other subjects,
you can subscribe to our newsletter,
which you can find on the footer
of any page on richroll.com.
Today's show was produced and engineered by Jason Camiolo.
The video edition of the podcast
was created by Dan Drake and Blake Curtis.
Portraits, courtesy of David Greenberg and Gracen Wilder.
Graphic elements are by Daniel Solis.
And our theme music was created by Tyler Pyatt,
Trapper Pyatt and Harry Mathis.
I appreciate the love.
I appreciate the support.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for watching.
See you back here soon.
Peace.
Plants.
Namaste.